After working in
R, you often want
to save your work so that you
can easily re-run commands
and rebuild models.
There are several
ways of doing this,
but the method we
recommend is by using
what's called a script file.
Let's open a new script file.
Go to File, New Document, on
a Mac, and File, New Script,
on a PC.
This will pop up a
blank script file.
You can copy and
paste any commands
that you've run in your
console into the script file.
For example, say we want to
save the table commands we ran.
Let's Copy the
first table command
and then Paste it
into the script file.
We can also take the
first tapply command
we ran, Copy and Paste
it into our script file.
Now, if you highlight
these lines of code
in the script file and press
Command-Enter on a Mac,
and Control-r on a PC, it
will run these lines of code
in your R console.
So if you save this
file and then reopen it
when you start R next time, you
can easily rerun any commands
that you ran in this R session.
A lot of times it's
easier to just write
commands in your script file
and run them in your console
because then they'll always
be saved in your script file.
You can add comments
in your script file
by using the pound sign.
If you type pound,
and then some comment
describing your script file, and
then highlight the whole thing
and press Control-r
or Command-Enter,
you'll see that the comment
runs in the console,
but nothing happens.
R recognizes this as a comment.
If you want to save the
output of your R session
in your console, I recommend
just saving it as a text file.
In your console, you can
go to file, Save to file,
and this will save your
output as a text file.
You won't be able
to easily rerun
this in R like the
script file, but it
will have the summary
output of what you did.
When you close R,
it will ask you
if you want to save
your workspace.
Make sure you have everything
you want in a script file
and then don't worry about
saving your workspace.
These are the basics
of R. We'll see
a lot more in the
rest of this class.
But hopefully you've
seen in this lecture
how powerful R can be.
In just one lecture, we
performed insightful data
analysis on an
interesting data set.> 00:03:24.550
of the population under 15.
We can do this with
the which.max function.
So type which.max and then
in parentheses WHO$Under15.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This tells us that
the 124th observation
has the maximum value
of the variable Under15.
We can look up the country of
the 124th observation by typing
WHO$Country and then
in square brackets 124.
Close the square
brackets and hit Enter.
So Niger is the country
with the maximum percentage
of the population under 15.
Let's now create a scatter plot
of GNI versus fertility rate.
You can do this using
the plot function.
So type plot and then
in parentheses WHO$GNI,
the variable we want
on our x-axis, comma,
and then WHO$FertilityRate, the
variable we want on our y-axis.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
A scatter plot should appear.
Income, or GNI,
is on the x-axis,
and fertility rate
is on the y-axis.
Each point in the scatter
plot is a country.
We can see that most
countries here either
have a low GNI or a high GNI
but a low fertility rate.
However, there are
a few countries
for which both the GNI and
the fertility rate are high.
Let's investigate.
We'll use the subset function
to identify the countries
with a GNI greater than
10,000, and a fertility
rate greater than 2.5.
So go back to your R console
and then type Outliers--
this is what we'll call
our subset-- equals subset,
and then in parentheses WHO
comma GNI greater than 10,000
and FertilityRate
greater than 2.5.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
When we used subset
before, we only
had one condition
to define which
observations to
keep in the subset.
Here we have two conditions,
separated by the and symbol.
This means that
both conditions must
be true for all
observations in the subset.
We can see how many rows
of data are in our subset
by using the nrow function.
So type nrow for number of
rows, and in parentheses
the name of our
subset, Outliers.
This tells us that there are
seven countries for which
the GNI is greater than
10,000 and the fertility rate
is greater than 2.5.
Now let's output just
the country names, GNI,
and fertility rate of
these seven countries
to investigate further.
There's an easy
way of doing this,
and we'll use this technique
several times in this class
when we just want to extract a
few variables from a data set.
So type the name
of our data set,
Outliers, and then
in square brackets
we'll make a vector of
the names of the variables
we want to output.
So c, and then in parentheses,
"Country" for the country name,
comma, "GNI" comma, and
then "FertilityRate".
Close th> 00:06:49.970
So we should expect
53 observations
in our Europe subset,
which is right.
Now, suppose we want
to save this new data
frame, WHO_Europe,
to a csv file.
You can use the write.csv
function to do this.
Type write.csv, and
then in parentheses
the name of the data
frame we want to save,
WHO_Europe, comma,
and then in quotes
the name of the file
we want to save it to.
Let's call it WHO_Europe.csv.
If you hit Enter,
nothing should happen,
but you should now have a
file called WHO_Europe.csv
in the same folder that
you saved WHO.csv in.
And now that we've saved
this as a csv file,
if we're not working
with it anymore in R,
we can remove the data frame
from our current session in R.
This is often useful if you're
working with a large data
set that's taking
up a lot of space.
First, let's type ls() to see
what variables we currently
have in R. You could see
that WHO_Europe is one
of our variables.
Now, type rm for remove and
then the name WHO_Europe and hit
Enter.
If you type ls() again, you
should see that WHO_Europe is
gone.
In the next video, we'll
explore the WHO data set.